containers set on narrow gauge rail
trucks awaiting delivery to lagos ports
for exports
a few years ago they would have to make
the journey by road
but a multi-billion dollar investment to
revive the country's rail system
is beginning to pay off
thanks to billions of dollars in loans
from china
thousands of kilometers of rail networks
have been revamped and put to use
opening up opportunities for businesses
and boosting the economy
jc wanker who operates freight services
so income grows steadily along with huge
growth potentials
we have not even scratched the system
we have a lot to carry in passenger
services
we have a lot to carry imports
even exports
movements of raw materials within the
country it's so huge when you put your
load on the train just go and sleep
it will deliver volumes
on time
save lives
you know and
employment benefits
at this train station in lagos these
passengers who commute daily from ibadan
for work and trading
catch the last train hall
just a year ago they'll have to spend
five hours on the road to get home
now they do that in two
officials now looking beyond passenger
services they've launched an ambitious
program to link up with nigeria's
neighbors and seaports to boost trade
we have developed what we call freight
years in abeculta and ibadah so that
we can have easy turnaround where people
can go and pick their containers
this he says will deliver freight in
time and ease pressure on nigerian roads
but the plan requires a lot of money
and the government doesn't have enough
it's estimated that 80 to 100 billion
dollars is required to fix nigeria's
rail network which has been neglected
for decades as a result trucks are the
main means of moving heavy loads across
the country and that has taken a heavy
toll on the roads which need hundreds of
millions of dollars of repairs every
year
the decline of nigeria's rail system
followed decades of neglect
much of the tracks were laid before the
country's independence in 1960
since then there was no major investment
in the sector
experts say reviving the sector will
spur growth in manufacturing and create
jobs
but there are concerns about whether the
government which currently owns and
operate the railways is capable of
sustaining it ahmedi trees al jazeera
lagos nigeria